what's up guys welcome back to another
episode of get close i'm geo and i'm
bart and we brought back our favorite
silent mic this is a second appearance
and as you guys know the second time
around we do things a little bit
different so if you missed his first
episode go check it out it's a [ __ ]
killer killer segment uh where basically
he talks about his [ __ ] for like the
whole time and it's so intriguing so
don't miss out but like my personality
not like my anatomy yes no but i was his
metaphorical [ __ ] i but i wanted to
leave it vague okay but thank you guys
anus too can we also just start off by
you said this is my favorite silence
yeah you are my favorite no but i'm your
favorite you are comma silent mike's
back
yeah like i'm not your favorite version
of silent mic yeah this one is my
favorite version no i know but like no
like i'm your favorite
what is it a
princeton comma harvard comma or
something
what are you talking about he's just
saying my english was stupid no no i'm
just making sure that we're all on the
same page yeah i mean that are they're
all correct all of those variations
because they're different so this
version of you on like we're filming i
like it when we're off camera i like it
but this one is my best i'm saying that
i'm like just your favorite yeah you are
and i was agreeing okay and i moved on
and i thought it was i thought it was
more can you hurry up with the questions
do you understand where the comma goes i
get it the fans want to know the answers
to their questions okay so um i went to
instagram and i like you guys know i
always ask you guys because i want you
guys to be in this room as well so you
guys have the power here and i'm asking
your questions
all right short answer long answer what
you need the long one oh long answers
yeah long answers always long enough
all right so we're going to start with
the funny one first
okay so a female she's saying why is he
going to be a female well let me finish
bro she's like uh is he single if so
what's his type asking for a friend
i don't know i think you bro that's good
um
yeah are you single and then what's your
type i would like to uh i'd like to say
that i'm alone not lonely
shut the [ __ ] up right
all the girls just go loser no that's
not true you don't know how to sell
yourself that's an answer for dudes and
all the dudes are probably going yeah
bro are you single yes or no i cry
myself to sleep looking for the princess
of my dreams okay good so you are single
yeah okay and a loser yeah yeah oh yeah
what's your type that i don't know uh
really i've explored this i know we got
deep into all of your stuff
here yeah all of your girlfriends
they've all looked different oh yeah 100
what about mentality or personalities
that's been really different all
different uh part of the issue is i got
like a co-dependency going thing going
on where uh i like to be like a
caretaker but i also get like two into
things and that's
probably what is good business-wise
right i die [ __ ] in i'm about it uh
but in relationships that's not always
healthy um and obviously things i'm
working on over the last thirty why
isn't a healthy relationship wise i
think if you get like two into something
it's probably not good well two in for
the pace i think probably that two and
then the other issue is that if you're
bringing up marriage on the street no no
no not like that that's like speeding
things up and being irrational i'm not
like that by any means but like the
other issue is that i'm not that social
so it's not like i have like eight
friend groups and i'm like friend friend
friend you know what i mean and so like
and i'm 33 life's just different beside
the point so i don't have a title it's
not beside the point that's a very big
point that is a big point and i operate
differently the older you become it's
like less [ __ ] and i've dated
multiple different personalities
multiple different some people maybe
maybe kind of had a following some
people didn't whatever whatever um but i
don't have a type of what i think i have
here and don't get mad you know the pc
police because i might be wrong i think
i'm demisexual what does that mean
come on dude i think i think it means
like that like and everyone's going to
say like yeah me too like no like demi
glace
what's that yeah i don't know what any
of these things i think
shout out to them even australia miss
you guys
i think it means that like personality
almost trumps looks and everyone's gonna
say like you have personalities yeah
that's [ __ ] every female on this
planet but that's not every dude no not
most dudes aren't i think no so that's
where i disconnect from a lot of dudes
because we're creatures of the eyes
and and but fertility is based on the
looks for the dude right if we're going
to evolutionary sense like oh like oh
she's got big boobies she can't my baby
really even in the animal kingdom that's
why a [ __ ] male peacock got big old
feathers yeah yes yeah um but they did a
study and i'm sure you probably know
this study no problem but they surveyed
men and women and they looked at what
their top three things are that they
look for in a significant other right
what was the study though just based on
verbal
um i don't remember you know though
because guys gave myself conscious like
he's not going to say like ass in
titties
it was that basically yeah so for men
the number one thing that they look for
in a significant other is attractiveness
yeah for sure but that's not to say that
the top three personality isn't in there
all right so i'll just give examples
like we will all work in the fitness
industry and so there's beautiful people
that we [ __ ] yeah they're
sculptures nuts right and so i've like
hung out with i like samia and panda too
he's he's a sculpture yeah he's a school
fan
i've hung out with the most beautiful
like women
and and men dude
of course but i'm just not attracted i
don't this so that's not my type if
that's what we want to draw lines i
didn't there we go that's not the line
okay good
like i would love you the same if it was
thanks i would love me the same too but
it's just not the thing okay uh you know
they say you got to try everything
before you know yeah don't knock it till
you try it no i don't have to try it i
know okay uh but the most i wouldn't
feel safe around you if
you think you're that hot
i'm gonna be getting after my booty boo
you think you're so hot that if i had an
ounce of gay in me i'm just gonna creep
in your bed dude you know how i know i'm
not a lesbian or like i have that
tendency or like you know every girl is
like oh i've kissed a girl just to kind
of see it you never have i've never i
never kissed a girl not because i'm
against it it's just i never had the
urge to yeah um you weren't drunk when i
like come here stephanie it was tequila
night yeah
no never actually kayla makes me kiss
girls
you sound like an ugly woman dude
um
but i had a dream that i was eating out
this chick and she was just about it she
was just in it i was killing the [ __ ]
cuta lingus game yeah i call it
catalinga catalina game just because no
one really knows what it is and i think
it's a city in california oh yeah
catalina
no catalina oh i never heard of it
so i was killing it right and in my
dream i was like damn i'm [ __ ] going
in this chick is enjoying it but the
entire time i was just completely
disgusted
and this is like then you started
feeling for bart
i do man i'm like how do guys like to do
that should this [ __ ] nasty well that
beat me like sucking on a [ __ ] i don't
want to be sucking on no [ __ ] yeah but
that's but like girls we're just more
like we're just innately closer to each
other you know what i mean like we're
just more yeah like we'll like
like like link up or sleep in the same
bed as a slumber party sleep in the same
bed i've never did that well like we'll
like touch each other's face like we're
just naturally closer so there's always
that like fine line of like oh
am i slightly bi or am i straight and
i've never had that the other thing too
is all humans appreciate like a hot
woman like you and i can because we're
into like bodybuilding kind of we're
like yeah that dude's jack but like
everyone's like yeah women are beautiful
yeah where no one's like men are
beautiful yeah yeah people don't really
do that outside of the fitness base not
really yeah yeah yeah every once in a
while you see a ken doll looking [ __ ]
and you're like yeah that dude's
pregnant that guy's pretty good looks
weird long story short hung out with a
hot chick she opened her mouth didn't
find her track like there's no way i
could do anything with this chick and
that's like the demi stuff like
personality trumps it hard well it's
important yeah no it is important but
most people i think think it's important
for like a life mate which is obviously
important right so you get along you got
to hang out all day but mine's even like
like anything sexual attraction anything
if they like are
something's wrong personally i could
relate to you super hard on that so in
college
um
there's this chick that i was talking to
when we were studying together she's
pretty cute
and airbus and then just right now i
don't care because you know the story i
know i'm the chef and um randomly we're
just studying we're just studying right
and then i was like it felt like a
really nice day so i'm like hey you want
to go to the beach and then she's like
yeah so we're going to the beach and
then i was like have you ever boogie
boarded before and i had my boogie board
so i taught her how to boogie board i'm
having a really good time and uh did you
kiss her no but then
not just like maybe like first second
date or second or third date or whatever
when i went home i made up my mind that
i don't like chicks that get distracted
uh because we're supposed to study and i
was able to distract her that's how
weird is you didn't do it on purpose no
it was but afterwards after because i
didn't know i was testing her but you
know like when you when you come home
you kind of have an assessment of the
day you're trapped yeah you have an
assessment of the day right i wonder how
is that i'm like do you want to see her
again no i just think i'm like
man we're supposed to study and she
[ __ ] got distracted that's a lazy
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's a lazy girl i'm like
i don't know if i could be [ __ ]
dating chicks that don't know how to
stick to their goals i hate you is that
part uh partly because you think when
you were dating how old were you
uh maybe like 23 maybe i'm still pretty
young do you think i was gonna say do
you think that partly because there's
difference between like dating and like
trying to bang or like hanging out with
hot chicks i've never had to try to bang
face or or is you're trying to find a
partner i think i was trying to figure
out
i never want to get married but i'm like
kind of like that too like i'm not going
to waste my time that's why i think i'm
different than a lot of dudes too yeah
and i know everybody says that like i'm
not the same as other guys
but i kind of like i i i never really
had that i don't i don't try to waste my
time with anything i like talking to hot
chicks like it's always fun like even
even guys sure yeah like who knows girls
or guys even guys if like if i find that
they're like really weird to me or like
like traits that i don't quite like i'm
like i don't think
and that i don't think that eventually
they can make it into my in in circle
i'm like yeah what do you what's inside
the point you keep just keeping them in
the circle yeah i don't have a type
though athletic we just talked about
that people do have a type uh it's going
to be someone that's about family
someone that i mean those that's a type
so they don't know the physical type no
no no so physical type after that be
funny i'm sure i don't know so what
physical type physical type uh athletic
tied in with the mentality of affluence
yeah and we were like kind of
competitive kind of cocky in a way
because i think that's just what i grew
up around like i love a cocky
[ __ ] i used to love like
basketball chicks and they're not like
historically always the prettiest but
like
bishop kind of walks in like kind of
baggy pants i'm like you you just know
you got it huh like but there's some
sort of confidence yeah that's kind of
how i rock a little bit even though i am
self-conscious sometimes i kind of carry
myself well um humor for sure like they
don't got to be funny um but as long as
you cuz i say dumb [ __ ] like so they
gotta have a sense of humor for sure
it's not talking about themselves i know
that's like a typical everyone says like
adventures and walks on the beach and
humor but like yeah like i'm just not
that serious i i think i i internally
i'm so serious that externally i can't
handle that so i don't want someone
super serious you know what i mean like
i think the three of us as friends are
even that balanced like we're always
[ __ ] around but like we can have
serious talks because all of us are
serious yeah but like our careers aren't
in a way you know our careers are a joke
yeah so like i need that yeah we were
joking in the car too you were listening
to like some sad love music and like you
don't listen to that because you never
broke your heart or something i was like
i can't listen to sad music because i am
sad no i was saying i know i understand
why the last girlfriend broke up with
you now yeah oh
[ __ ] now she's you now she's watching
too yeah god damn it um i agree with you
okay so that's kind of that's a type
yeah yeah yeah no they're in there but
but there hasn't been like a consistency
in it but i know what i i think i know
what i want rather than a type i see you
know what i mean i'm chiseling down what
i want you're figuring it out yeah
stability and all that kind of stuff's
important you know um
we're driven to some nature they they
don't got to do anything crazy but like
i have a job
an adult man i'm old yeah you know i own
a house you own a house at school but if
she doesn't want
i didn't think i want to get married
until like two years ago oh wow and i
don't even know if i want to get married
mary but like a partner but now it's uh
opening up to the a partner in crime
would be cool because i am why what's
wrong with getting married nothing
nothing i think just the term in my head
i have issues and again like i had sick
parents they were married they were
married until my dad died super in love
great we know you got issues i got
issues yeah and i just don't know i feel
like you're not special bro we all have
the same i'm special you got the same
issue towards the word marriage as you
do discipline like oh okay what is
happening and love i got an issue with
love i found out that word makes me feel
weird i only like saying it like that so
when i tell you i love you makes you
feel it's hard dude that's why i'll send
you a little heart hey do you love dogs
yeah yeah that's different i love you
bro just stop wait why is that different
dude i like i love pokemon because
they're never gonna break his heart
because they're always they're just
unconditionally we're gonna cry by the
end of this one that's what it is i
think that was the same no i really am
vulnerable i don't we threw it around
the house okay but just to my parents
um with other humans i also think i had
um i got trust issues uh from being
screwed over whether it be
relationship-wise or business i would
never screw you over yeah i see yeah so
loyal you could kick them and they're
still gonna see you the next day go oh
my god i love you so much and i think
i'm i think i'm a loyal [ __ ]
like i'm down to ride like i'm going to
wear a barber brigade to the day i die
kind of stuff you know and you guys but
what if we're about to get on a fight
are you going to jump in is that is that
your loyalty rolling dog these fists are
throwing i'm going to hire some actors
oh chuck yeah you better give them
insurance because they're gonna get
[ __ ] up too you're gonna do some bust
some juicy sommelier [ __ ] yeah i have
some actors to beat you minus the
[ __ ] racism yeah yeah yeah that was
just checking loyalty yeah so like
loyalty on a different level like yeah
like cheating and blah blah blah like
like a down dog like a ride or die you
know yeah yeah cause i'm like that
circle small do you love ice cream i
love ice cream so you can only say love
towards things that can't hurt you i
think i can only say love towards things
that can't love me back bro well dogs
love you stop dogs dogs love you you
love me i'll text it to you later you're
a weird man no i'm weird i got issues
for you you have to practice that a lot
i'd love you to like even when i don't
like i've been doing it to like my
brothers like so by your
mom i know but i love you i had eyes
really hard right now all right you
really put me on the spot i love you oh
gee i love you too no but it was good we
got to look i know but i looked at your
other half
that was the first try that was probably
the first time i've said that ever i
love you dude guys get out of here maybe
start waking up at 4am and [ __ ] say
love better all right that's a reference
from the last podcast please listen to
it so you can get all these inside jokes
i uh yeah no i do have issues with it
like my little bro he's literally like
my little brother i've known him since
he was in diapers his older brother's my
best friend since third grade like he'll
say it all the time and he's obviously
just much better off than i am and i'll
try to say it back and i kind of love
you too dude hang up real quick
that's [ __ ] cute man i i'm gonna keep
telling you i love you i know but that i
know when i can like comfortably say
that around a chick that's probably the
chick you know yeah true probably yeah
that's true all right so this one's kind
of dude there's a bunch of chicks what's
up ladies get it in girl i see you okay
so you can find me on plenty of fish and
fitnessdates.com you're lying
um so this one ties into what we just
talked about so she was asking average
looking chick with a bomb personality or
a fine chick with an average personality
average looking chick with them cakes
and the good person it has to be cakes
god got cakes that's an athlete
true i need quads and cakes yeah quakes
and quads cakes cakes and i like quakes
yeah i gotta got quakes yeah um that's
true you can't have you can't be an
athlete and then not have cakes yeah i
mean even on the feet there's some
athletes that have the quads and not the
cakes it depends where we're not engine
crop properly yeah it depends what we're
talking about athlete right because i
don't want to get into that like there's
some what if she's a golfer huh i love
golf
good golfers got cakes too they got
cakes dude golfers started listening
swimmers don't always have cakes and
they've got shoulders and they're tall i
don't have a tall issue but i feel like
girls have more of a tall issue than i
do most girls yeah yeah i mean i'm 5 10.
i don't give a [ __ ] if they're hitting
the butterfly they might have cakes
because they got the dolphin kick they
got some
um yeah no uh if you you can you date an
older i mean a a taller chick yeah i
don't care i don't care like a lot
taller yeah bro i'm confident if she's
6'5
if she's attractive and the rest hits
yeah whatever okay bro with my jumper
and handles we're going to the nba
a tag team yeah a sixth man on that
little our little dude
uh no um average
looks
there's got to be an attractive on the
on the looks too the personality can
only take you so far you know so if
you're looking like you know
not true man i had a really ugly
boyfriend in high school and he was just
so cool chicks are so different though
when have you ever seen that that's true
you're so wired differently yeah sorry
if you're listening you see some hot
chicks with the most ugly gross looking
neck beard dudes walking around the mall
you never see that you don't see a dan
bilzerian with like eight of the ugliest
[ __ ] you think he's good looking no i'm
just saying like
no no stereotypically i'm just talking
about like you don't attract you don't
see when there is a girl a dude that has
access to a lot of females oh you don't
see look at my eight ugly [ __ ] yeah
yeah no no no stephanie's really funny
in the hot tub that's why stephanie's
here
she's a sick swimmer
okay um so this one's kind of tied
together but i'll break it out this is a
dating show no no no no it's not dating
anymore we're moving on we're moving on
okay how long have you been lifting for
since eighth grade oh wow eighth grade
because i am a five eight italian man uh
were you five eight in eighth grade bra
is the same size i was a savage i
grabbed rim in seventh grade what the
[ __ ] what kind of rim
uh basketball rim freak uh i was like
yeah
are you over 150 already and uh probably
i was probably about a buck 60. wow
going into high school i think freshman
year i was probably five nine or
whatever height i am right now in a buck
seventy i gained a little weight junior
year like not goodish weight got up to
like a buck ninety worked my tits off to
get back in to about 180 it's kind of my
plan i was four six yeah i would have
punched your legs i know four six
ninety pounds in eighth grade that was
me like fourth grade and and i'm not
that tall uh my dad was probably five
five five six
um but yeah i played basketball and i
was super into basketball like um how
did you get was it because of basketball
your coach was like you need a weight
train because that's a new concept no no
no it was my dad my dad was cool and he
he knew i wanted a dunk and be faster
and be more durable how did he know he
played college football and rugby um i
don't really know
yeah i don't really know my sister was a
little bit older my dad wasn't even like
a lifter by any means he wasn't like a
gym rat by any means um
i don't know but he just understood
strength and conditioning a little bit
yeah i think he just knew that that's
where people got to get better they got
trainers like my sister went to this
trainer too she was a little bit older
so she went to him in high school
he trained like a bunch of european pros
and mvps uh this chick who's my shooting
coach danielle viglione
one of the best ross chick players in
the world she played at texas and then
played in like israel germany mvp
overseas
another dude named andre woldridge who
who was a point guard from iowa played
over in italy and stuff and then a bunch
of football players mostly nfl and mixed
um i don't know why i was just lucky i
guess my dad's like yeah and then he was
another amazing mentor of mine his name
is also dean so my high school coach was
shouted out in our other podcast and
this guy both named dean wow big
influence i've never met a dean really
yeah both of them are dean uh very
different very different looking very
different styles my strength and
conditioning coach most loving kind guy
in the world uh but he
was a drill sergeant for drill sergeants
oh cool
so he he'd be [ __ ] around with me and
joking with me you know because
everybody else there was a little bit
different different upbringing a little
bit different than i which kind of
was my mix because i went to a private
school i went to a private arts school
and so you know a lot of asian kids and
white kids a little different
than strength and conditioning i'm
playing with pro athletes and people
from underprivileged schools that are
just freak athletes and so that kind of
gave me a scope on life i think yeah
because everyone sees me uh you know i
dance i listen to rap music and wear
jordans and stuff and then like you went
to art school you little [ __ ] weirdo
i'm like yes i did
uh but like my i went free i i wasn't
raised like stupid privileged uh we were
middle class middle middle class super
normal family but that kind of opened my
eyes to a lot of the world um but back
to being a drill sergeant he'd be
[ __ ] around with me and then
sometimes if you're slacking bro he whip
out that voice
like that yeah yeah it was good yeah i
like a coach that [ __ ] gets on yeah
he's a bad and he's jacked as [ __ ] i
never saw him without a crew neck on
it'd be 100 degrees he had a crew deck
on i'd [ __ ] with him a little bit you
know and he flexed on you like oh god
yeah you get your ass and then long
story short did he have a whistle all
the time no no his voice bro he'd kill
you long story short kyle who manages my
gym now is my roommate one of my best
friends his dad is best friends with my
strength and conditioning coach and i
just i just met kyle when i was like 28.
oh [ __ ] yeah sex small bro this podcast
is sponsored by ziprecruiter okay so
right now we live in an era where we are
all entrepreneurs we're all
self-employed
and for a lot of us we're doing really
well to the point that we need to expand
our team
this is where zip recruiter is going to
save you the time that you already don't
have to look for qualified
quality high caliber candidates i
personally have used zip recruiter on
multiple occasions when looking for
different team members for
either jk films or barbell brigade or
even for get close
companies and it's been a breeze i
absolutely love it all i did was write
down the position the requirements
any details for that job i posted and
honestly within hours i started getting
email submissions of potential
candidates it was beautiful ziprecruiter
uses its powerful technology to find
and match the right candidates
up with your job uh then it proactively
presents these candidates to you so
instead of me sitting there and
filtering through
you know different job sites um and then
just different uh filtering through like
different candidates and stuff what it
does is it sorts it for me and then it
does like this quick review so um
it works like as a rating system so all
i get to do is thumbs up if i like them
thumbs down if i don't like them or i
may be it and before going into too many
details with that all i do is thumbs up
then it's down or in the middle for
maybe and i sort through it really
really quickly and then i look through
when i'm done sorting then i just go
through only my thumbs up if i find
someone there great if i don't then i go
through my maybes um but i just love how
i just have to do minimal work you can
easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply for your job
which encourages them to apply faster
so no wonder it's uh zip recruiter is
number one rated hiring site in the us
based on a g2 rating zip recruiter
technology is so effective that four out
of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a qualified quality
candidate within the first day and i can
attest to that that is so true so right
now
listen because i'm about to hook you
guys up uh find the right employees for
your workplace with ziprecruiter try it
for free
at this exclusive web address okay it's
going to be ziprecruiter.com
get close
again it's exclusive you have to use
this website
ziprecruiter.com
get close g-e-t-c-l-o-s-e
again you're gonna get that for free so
do it
damn uh when you first touched your
weight yeah uh like in a gym yeah were
you like instantly hooked because
there's some people that are just like
oh
yeah
i did like it but i i think even now we
talk offer on her about like i just
don't love powerlifting i like training
in a group environment like even today
was like one of my most fun workouts
lifting with you all um
dying yeah but whatever we were just
together like music
but that's part of training as a group
which is awesome yeah yeah i love it by
yourself kind of sucks yeah yeah yeah
even my workout like i was i was
planning to pull like 600 this week and
i only pulled 500 just because of travel
and you know new gym or whatever like it
wasn't my best physical workout but it
was the most fun yeah um and we trained
like that with this group so it's like
five or six of us they're all like
football players basketball players me
i love that and so i think i was
addicted to that right away yeah rather
than like and the pump felt good when
you're like you know 14 and you leave
and you're like can't drive because your
biceps are pumped it's like a cool
feeling yeah it feels it literally feels
like it's growing yeah yeah yeah it was
stupid when i was that young um so i
like that i think yeah i get it um okay
so that one's kind of tied to this
uh how would you feel if you could never
lift again so i guess i'll wrap it up a
little bit more and not necessarily lift
but just train in any capacity you know
like the would you rather's i think i
saw one online that was like uh never
listen to music or never lift again and
it was like in the meathead thread you
know and i was like i was like i would
easily never lift like i love music wow
okay but no music yeah but i'm not
allowed i'm not allowed to [ __ ] like
walk or nothing no train i'll yeah i'll
make it like and health health would be
okay though or yeah yeah oh that's fine
yeah i'm fine dude wow
i could chalk it up right now i'll throw
my wraps and belt on the wall so you'll
if you never move again you're pretty
sedentary no more training you're just
yeah if health stuff's fine yeah if
health stuff's unrelated yeah i train
now like it really is health and even in
the beginning like i was i was motivated
by basketball i was motivated to lead
for my family my family's not that
healthy um extended family and even my
dad
he wasn't like crazy like five six 220
like not super slim but he wasn't like
crazy you know he refereed basketball
leagues all day and jogged but
i knew my family had heart issues and i
know my extended family is a little
larger so that was always kind of a
motivating factor to talk about mike
tyson i heard mike tyson trained a lot
because uh his family was overweight i
don't know how true that is because i
know his family's broken up but i heard
that he also just started boxing when he
was like in fifth grade and he was doing
it on cocaine probably yeah and i knew
his family was broken but i heard
something like that or maybe he opened a
gym or maybe it was even another boxer
but i just heard stories like that i was
like that's cool that relates to me a
lot um and and
i do it to lead i do to lead for my
company i do it to lead for my other
lifters i do it to lead for my audience
um i would choose music over training
too yeah i just do it's like waking up
to showering for me i almost can't even
train without music no for sure not yeah
like the those two training to me is
literally like dancing with weights yeah
yeah it's like the it's part of the vibe
in the group it's like imagine watching
a movie with no soundtrack that same
idea is like i love the garage like uh
gates up hot i love barber gate i love
third shoe like i need the heat i need a
sweat i need to see other people kind of
work in yeah yeah i love that yeah um if
if i could never train again i think i
would i would feel weird really yeah i
don't need to wait like i don't know
i don't need to lift weights
um but i i like that community and i
like suffering with people like i like
um
hiking is that liv is that training oh i
guess cause i can still do communal
things yeah but i like but it's
different right because you can do a
picnic and that's communal but like
going through some [ __ ] together and
then coming out the other side and going
like [ __ ] what about the psychological
effect in your question i know i'm
digging then the question doesn't answer
that but like the psychological effect
like humans are made to do some [ __ ]
yeah like i don't you guys are probably
at some point and the listeners probably
at some point done like a lot of
construction like it [ __ ] feels good
you know like a [ __ ] rip and drywall
and i'm [ __ ] i feel like a man yeah
like that feels maybe that's more of a
man thing i don't know you've never felt
that good i don't think women feel that
i feel it with training
like when i'm sweating into shock and
i'm [ __ ] bleeding i'm like that was
kind of good
i like that
good
that's a lot of people like blue collar
jobs yeah because like
after the eight-hour day you see a
progression like oh cool we put up three
sides of the drywall or whatever versus
a white-collar job you're staring at
spreadsheets all day you're like i don't
really even know what the effect of what
i did is not to switch jobs but talking
about getting older and figuring things
out like that's something i figured out
way older in life that i chose the wrong
profession for what satisfies my
workload like what i like seeing job
work complete yes youtube's never
complete
running a gym ain't never complete
apparently never complete like
like i talked to my barber uh
as like he's cut my hair for like six
years we're homies now and he's like
yeah i love my job like mess half an
hour later i make something good he
leaves i was like dude that's beautiful
like renovating the gym felt so good
yeah because you're you you actually
finish yeah and they're like okay
doorframe good like okay now we gotta go
to this okay now we're gonna go paint
this now i'm gonna do the floor like
yeah that's all so good i mean you can
shift to [ __ ] to that right like you can
do different seasons and segments for
youtube if it's but the algorithm is
crushes you trying to do a season
wouldn't even even it does but you don't
stop so it's a season of like maybe i
don't know [ __ ] challenges the next
season is something else you know i
think the other issues but yeah you're
right it's [ __ ] hard and even that
like you could see it on the micro like
uh concept shoot edit publish as a
project but the content circles so fast
like our news cycle like it's 12 hours
and so like i know you know by the time
you edit the video and press go live
like you sh you already have to have
your next concept or your next video
your next vlog started yeah um so it
never like feels good yeah it is kind of
rough yeah i was trying to make it into
a positive god damn you're noisy when
did you guys start lifting
i started lifting in my freshman year in
high school yeah yeah me it was in
college because of sports i was benching
and crawling every day really it wasn't
uh wrestling related because wrestlers i
feel like lyft yeah i wrestled after so
i first started lifting because that's
what all the gangsters did yeah and so i
was like okay cool like all that's what
all my older homies are telling me to do
so i bought like a little bench set from
uh big five oh yeah and then my dad was
just about anything that was in any
direction positive oh so that's cool so
he was like okay that seems like a
positive thing it's better than asking
for cigarettes or whatever yeah so we're
going to big five and i bought you know
those cheap like the the kind of like
weight kind of kind of the rotate on
like the collars rotate on and then i
was just benching and curling when i
needed a spot i'd go ask my dad and he'd
come out and spot him how cute and i'm
just batching a clown over there i
didn't like train train but i i think i
was always self-conscious as a kid maybe
it's like the societal thing i always
wanted like abs and [ __ ] so my parents
bought me one of those when i was like
fourth fifth grade i didn't really know
how to use it i did like a curl every
once in a while but i i always had abs i
did kung fu as a kid yeah but i never
had like uh i wanted to be like beefy
looking i'd never want i always wanted
to be skinny even still i don't like how
big i am what
interesting never i've always been
self-conscious wow
i didn't i so i got into weight training
because of sports which is rare too
like chicks lift chicks lifting it was
rare yeah now that i look back at it i
was like whoa we were in the gym like
bunching yeah like we would do pool
exercises too just to help our hops yeah
that's cool um so i'm like oh [ __ ] we
had a pretty cool coach
but before then like kind of like you
where my family runs deep in like the
health and like the overweight [ __ ] um i
was just obsessed with like being
slimmer and like i would do push-ups in
my room like i would always do like we
had a stationary bike and i was like the
only one [ __ ] on it you know like nor
to track and [ __ ] you remember that i
was all that yeah i bought like shitty
ab machines yeah because i think my mom
was into fitness they say like uh or
maybe they don't say and i say or maybe
it's anecdotal or maybe it's a real
thing uh like if your parents are
alcoholics you're either gonna end up an
alcoholic or like a straight edge yeah
right it's like same thing if like your
family's unhealthy you're gonna end up
looking at health free or you end up
unhealthy because i have there's four of
us that i have three other siblings and
i'm the only one that's kind of not
obsessed because i'm not obsessed but
like oh yeah it's part of your lifestyle
yeah i don't know
all right i got another one for you
europe um how did you get your name
silent mike um so silent mike started uh
at super training gym um i started going
to the gym and
uh
we talked a little bit in the other
podcast
like i'm not diagnosed or anything but
like a kind of split personality uh i
tend to be shy and i also tend to
observe before i hop in um so when i
joined super training gym which is a
very uh iconic powerlifting gym and at
the time even arguably even more iconic
within the niche although powerlifting
was less popular it had a
bunch of world record holders um
everybody was like
at least 280 pounds or heavier
everybody the other youngest person
which i didn't know he was he was like
probably 28 but everybody was like mid
30s late 30s or older everybody used
powerlifting gear and so for those
listening basically it's
if you think of like formula one versus
nascar they're both racing cars but they
have different like rules on what you
can modify the engines
and so we all power lift and we just
kind of use knee sleeves and a belt but
geared power lifting they use
literally think of skin tight double
layered denim overalls and so these
things are grabbing your waist so you
can squat more weight or bench more
weight et cetera et cetera they all did
that and i only lifted raw i only lifted
with a belt
um
a plus being the youngest plus coming
from a basketball background like it's
just so different um and so i just kind
of like shut up nut up just kind of
worked for like three months
yeah and then a couple times like
i thought it was like super serious you
know and something like in this thing
like i thought it was like a real sport
and then turns out like powerlifting is
you know it's not really a real sport uh
in my opinion like it's just not like
that you know like there's athletes that
go hard you know but like generally
speaking and so i'm showing up every day
like half an hour early like i'm
treating like basketball practice oh
[ __ ] and i'm there every single day like
the team trained together and i started
noticing like oh that guy only comes in
like tuesdays like he's not really about
it and i think mark who owned the gym
was kind of started to notice that too
and he and although he squatted a
thousand pounds and i squatted 500. he
he started having me work out with him
um just because i was about it you know
yeah and so then they put me in some
youtube videos um
and because i didn't really talk in
training they just called me silent mike
i think jim said hey uh jim mcdews my
business partner said like hey we should
go interview that quiet mic guy and then
when the camera turned on mark just said
silent mic oh nice yeah so i just kept
it i love it yeah
yeah it's kind of cool and then now it's
like kind of ironic because i am loud
yeah yeah you don't shut the [ __ ] up
comfortable you know yeah [ __ ] she
doesn't shut the [ __ ] up mike
yeah me and tyka dude we just rattle him
dude you ain't talking together i'm like
thank god because [ __ ] man i don't think
i could do it for a year but like a week
i can [ __ ] hang with tycoon
oh yeah he's nuts 24 7. look at us we're
[ __ ] i've aged 10 years since i've
had this dude no you're just old enough
oh bro [ __ ] i knew that was coming you
set yourself up for that one i know but
we got to give we got to give the people
what they want you know
um get some people going yeah
provocative
all right so favorite album no skips oh
dude so i'm a big no skip guy and i'm a
big skip guy she will literally skip
after the first 10 seconds skippity
and she'll play it and then she skips
and i just started vibing with it it's
my favorite song and i've heard it a
million times
are you trying to share something with
me or not really no because that's like
hey i just tried this cookie you take a
bite and then you take it out of the
person's mouth yeah yeah because i'm
just like just taste it but i've i
didn't make it i don't even want to
smell it anymore but did you it's i have
good taste right cool that's all i want
oh it's a self-affirmation yeah yeah
from people that i care about i bet you
you listened you like a listening party
i bet you listen party and you have it
on shuffle
uh no
no shuffle uh maybe i do loser maybe
sometimes brand new album oh no not not
a brand new brand new album you gotta go
front to back and that's how i judge an
album even though artists necessarily
don't put that much thought into it
anymore i argue i think they do but i
bet they try but it's there's it's like
a movement it's like a symphony and so a
good album i think will draw that out of
you
best album no skips bro there's a lot
that maybe aren't the best albums but
like just
you know like uh have nostalgia on your
brain or like yeah there's something so
uh distant relatives which nas and
damian marley that was a big up that's
not number one i'm not the doctor i'm
just i'm like that just came out like a
female i'm just throwing samples out
there you know just look at that right
that yeah that's not that old maybe 10
years that's one of your top five though
uh top ten
no go up to top five okay i was just
fine
i was building up the what they are no i
think it's going to be different now too
like do people still listen to albums no
so i do but they don't then that's their
problem yeah uh so i don't
that's your problem better i want the
bangers and that's it well that's what
people want that's your problem but
distant relatives like uh i got into as
i started to travel a lot
and so i just listened to it a lot while
i'm traveling what's up stop talking
about what's top five yeah [ __ ]
i don't want to talk about something you
don't care about top five probably the
carter [ __ ] dude i can't do it can i can
i throw three albums in one category
yeah i like that so carter well one two
three are in the top five together kind
of okay um i listen a lot of mixtape
wrapped i was why why is the card on one
two and three like one i think they're
absolute bangers i think uh wayne's
one of the few rappers that really mixes
um lyrical genius with like club hitters
um and even you and i were talking about
like pr songs that hit us that aren't
necessarily club bangers they could be a
little more low-key but they give you
something yeah they hit the veins he can
hit the veins pretty good um and
probably just a time of my life that was
like when i was let me give you another
a better question you're going to jail
for a life you can what album you get to
choose one album oh that's a better
question that's good
good job babe
that's a good one [ __ ] what i picked
yeah see i don't know
probably
probably like a bob marley greatest hits
because i know him be angry in there i
listen to a lot of like a lot of my
stuff's mood based like a lot of people
too but a lot of my music when i'm
chilling is happy music what about like
afrovision i have mine like a lot of
people i'm thinking about
uh because i'm hearing you talk and i'm
like dang like i need something that has
a lot of movement and i think it would
probably be uh
uh frank ocean's orange oh wow that's a
good album yeah that's an amazing album
but everything i'm not listening to that
in jail that's it has everything so do
you know what's gonna happen to my booty
when my neighbor hears that song
wait is it horse gump dude somebody say
tornado yeah i'm not listening to that
prison
yeah forrest gump what about a michael
jackson throw that's one that's a really
good album yeah amazing it's a great
album but it like
you're in prison right like yeah you
need some others no i might do it i
might do michael jackson in prison he
could have a good time yeah
because he has all kind there's beat it
on there yeah but it has a standard it
has pyramids bro
that's a good album that's a good album
and then you slow it down like the
forest gump you know there's that one
and then there's the [ __ ] the tornado
but there's no dad there's no dancing
hits in there pyramid yeah it's all
right i need like happy ass music if i'm
in prison yeah just in general i love r
b uh as all of us we kind of share a 90s
r b vibe together but um
a lot of it is sad and i'm a sad dude i
can't listen to sad music all the time
that's why it's a lot of afrobeats i
don't know like an exact album because i
just make my own playlist now but yeah
you throw some elite barry get my hips
moving in prison i think my favorite
album all the time i've had to choose
one is uh kanye west storytellers
uh v8 kanye west storyteller the vh1 one
have you seen it no and i love connor he
does this live set
and i think he picked and choose his
favorite songs from his other albums and
he put it together and it's like a
medley where one song bleeds into the
other but he's doing it live and he does
kind of semi-commentary on it and it
sounds like a live album so it doesn't
sound like uh fully produced and
mastered in that way yeah but it gives
it that extra raw life energy and then
the the good life
like that song's on there because i
thought it was kanye too yeah yeah yeah
but i wanted to go with an album right i
don't know if that would that would
qualify as an album it's an album i
don't know either it's a it's a recorded
live special we'll call it a sp
special all right all right but either
way kanye was going to be one of them
but but i could honestly choose any of
his first like six albums they're
[ __ ] bangers yeah college dropbox
graduation the only one i'm not a big
guy don't say [ __ ] 808 in heartbreaks
because that's like one of my favorites
no i like 808's um oh yeah you are sad
boy yeah yeah and it's like it's like
melody that was like my [ __ ]
breakfast yeah it's like a problem dude
i didn't love yeezus of his new stuff
but i like i like a lot of connie's
music man i like life of pablo i like a
lot of stuff but graduation might be on
that list uh there's another one that
just popped in my head when you were
singing
to the kanye uh maybe no somebody else
that would bring it to prison
all right i think i think that's good
that's good that's good you get an idea
yeah i get it yeah lupin uh uh the cool
or or food and liquor by lupe those are
big albums in my life oh that was a good
yeah that's a good air too really big
albums uh lauren push is that the kick
push era yep yep misunderstood by lauren
hill might absolutely be like mars a
bruno marston that's my boy [ __ ]
it's an album full of bangers dude and
what's crazy
you haven't even showed the [ __ ]
bro
hey so i train at my gym at like nine or
ten o'clock sometimes because no that's
10 pm uh am cause that's kind of the
dead period you get the morning crowds
out and yeah people creeping around noon
and i just me and kyle dude we just
turned that the [ __ ] up there's a vlog
coming out where i didn't know kyle was
filming we swear to god and i'm [ __ ]
on the dumbbells like this just [ __ ]
feeling myself
it's just such a good song it's like so
sting inspired like yeah yeah yeah yeah
rips dude you can hear all the people
that he's inspired by yeah like by song
yeah oh i was gonna say something oh the
kanye all the kanye albums are ones that
work top to bottom that's what i was
gonna say uh yes um like he he does such
a good job of building it up and telling
a story he's a [ __ ] artist yeah yeah
and bruno and bruno's like that uh dude
this guy was into bruno before bruno was
even bruno that story
um because of him did you you never
showed me that you told me the story i
got a picture with them and i went to a
concert where there's literally five
people there yeah dude
dude one of his opening acts was this
weird [ __ ] folk like guitar player
that was handing out like dollar bills
remember because the crowd was so little
this guy was like that was his gimmick
he gave us a dollar and we were like
what the [ __ ] good luck weird and all
those songs that like before he made it
big they're [ __ ] phenomenal yeah but
the world will never hear them but
they're amazing songs i love them yeah
okay uh so kind of along the lines of
music yeah someone wants to know where
did you get those dance moves from like
who's a dancer how did what how did we
get this that's probably like my most
asked question and people like half joke
or not but like teach me how to dance
like i'm not a dancer i love dancing and
i love dancers and i would never that's
kind of like like uh appropriation type
[ __ ] to me like i'm not going to call
myself a dancer if i [ __ ] i'm not a
dancer
i think you know like i respect dancers
so i would never call myself a dancer
like that kind of deal yeah yeah i don't
think anyone's thinking you're [ __ ]
professional some people swear to god
asking me to teach them how to dance
hey a dude hit me up hell it was sad too
i want to help me he's gonna pay you to
teach him how to dance i think so i
don't know if he had a wedding or like a
dance go to say hey man what are some
like simple stuff i could maybe do in
the clubhouse
you're asking the wrong or maybe because
you look after each other
maybe they're like he looks like he
knows how to dance he doesn't know how
to dance don't have to be a professional
i got gigs is what we'd say in the north
i don't know if they say that in l.a no
the north the north of what nor northern
cali okay giggs you never heard gigs no
he got gigs no gigs music got moves oh
cool yeah that's a little bit older term
um i just because of basketball in
whatever reason i just grew up watching
a lot of bet and music videos so even so
not even like your parents or no i mean
i'm latin
yeah but that doesn't mean anything yeah
but yeah like stereotypically it does
right if both of your parents are latin
and then you go to the [ __ ] dad could
kind of sing oh really yeah i could kind
of sing like you'd be messing around in
the car or something but you're like hey
your voice kind of in there yeah i could
see what about the hips what about your
dad's hips so how were those oh he had
rhythm i mean he ain't moonwalking but
he had like i would see him messing
around like we whenever we did chores or
something they'd be thumping some
creatures clearwater bill withers or
something dad move a little bit like he
he wasn't awkward he had rhythm mom has
rhythm plays a little guitar a little
piano uh she's a little bit more like me
though where i think she can sing but
both our voices actually suck but we can
sing if that makes sense if you play
music you kind of know what i mean like
we got tune we got pitch we got rhythm
but my voice just sucks um i don't know
honestly just bt and i thought dancing
was cool so i just like keep rewinding
that's the only thing i use for youtube
i just keep rewinding like 30 seconds of
usher's dance moves you know yeah
and that's how i learned how to like
glide and like moonwalk
nice yeah all right i just think it's
cool and and it's like just yeah it's
just how i have fun i need a dancer
though yeah i think it's also confidence
too i think a lot of dancing has to do
with confidence like you don't have to
be the best dancer but if you are
[ __ ] feeling it and you're like in it
you could be doing like this weird
shoulder thing but if you believe in it
it looks good and you have to go harder
people think dancing yeah here's mike's
non-dancer dancer advice yeah people
think small moves are it you know like
that shoulder thing like if you're just
doing this like yeah because the
confidence makes you hate them [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah dude we did a [ __ ] music video
that tim chantrangs who was always
making fun of uh so we did a cover of
black and yellow right oh yeah i
probably heard it i always show you guys
all the money it's disgusting so stupid
okay but the point why i'm bringing it
up one because i'm ashamed of it but not
really because i don't give a [ __ ] the
two is we had a music video component to
this right yeah so we find this [ __ ]
location that has like this graffiti ass
wall and [ __ ] and we're outside and it's
gorilla style shooting
and like now it's like my verse to like
[ __ ] you rap yeah yeah i did i have
my verse and like in my head i felt like
i was doing that shoulder [ __ ] you know
where i'm like [ __ ] like i was
feeling it yeah and i was like doing
this thing and then i watch the footage
and i'm literally moving like this yeah
you're tapping your toe yeah and i was
like what the [ __ ] it was bad yeah it is
kind of hard to go home
yeah i i felt i felt in it you think you
can teach rhythm yeah i don't know if
you can i think you could teach it
i think so my whole school yeah we you
had to play music every single year and
be in the choir every single year from
like third grade until senior year and
some kids just can't like count fours
yeah
you could maybe you could teach someone
to count fours yeah you can't tell teach
someone to feel for us yeah oh that's
yeah that's different that's different
yeah yeah but yeah i was like saying
like there's a mathematical way to go
about it and i think they can do it but
you know like some people play the same
beat and there's just the groove yeah
like they're maybe they're like waiting
a little bit
later on the two and the four to drop
something like yeah there's like it's
the same exact beat right but it just
just by pulling the beats apart a little
bit it feels different
that i don't think you can teach that
was me i was the very because me and bar
talk drumming you said yeah i'm like
dude
and then i saw you drawing like i'm not
like that it's kind of like my dancing
like i'm not a drummer
either no you're better than me i didn't
have like chops but i had some [ __ ] i
had some
lip girl
god
don't do that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
primal
you're so stupid
all right so we all know that um you've
talked about this so many damn times
about just having adhd and just like
like just working through that [ __ ]
right so someone wants to know what are
your tips on staying focused to complete
tasks both in work and in the gym i'm
not a doctor uh so there's that
i think we all know that bro i don't
know dude i look pretty white collar uh
i also uh i'm like pseudo-diagnosed
they're like about to diagnose me but
they don't really diagnose you unless
they're gonna give you meds and so my
therapist like do you want me to say i
ain't taking no meds and so i never got
a fifty dollars did you say [ __ ] yes
dude [ __ ] yeah
yeah
that's a key appeal uh sketch um
so for me i think and all these things
are like not only spectrum of how
exaggerated your symptoms are or your
things
but also
they can show up in different ways and
so my adhd kind and it kind of ties into
my anxiety where
productivity is not an issue oh
unproductivity is so if i know i have
work to do i can't do anything or
concentrate on anything else
right if i know i have emails to to
write or whatever a read i can't have
breakfast or do a podcast with you guys
until i get that done it sits on my head
i won't think of anything else so it's
also kind of good though no for me it's
really good yeah i get like all my like
work work done in like two hours in the
morning i'm done because i just i can't
do that yeah um so i want that so i
don't have a lot of answers from my guy
really but what i do rely on for a lot
of people um in the past podcast we
talked about discipline and and building
routine and stuff like that and that's
what it is for me is i like to build
micro whether you want to call them
superstitions or traditions or routines
around everything i do
so that's from
how i get ready to work out that's how i
get ready to travel that's how i get
ready to what's an example so uh to work
out it's a little different now because
i'm my gym schedule's messed up but like
in the perfect day like uh my whole
day's planned out in my head or if you
need to write it down but it's like eat
at a certain time i like a certain meal
when i eat i eat two hours before and
then i like to shower before i work out
it makes me feel better and wake up and
i listen to bruno mars or something that
gets me in a good mood not necessarily
an angry lift mood blah blah blah blah
and works similar for me if in my
perfect world um
i want to know the blah blah the blah
blah depend uh so it depends on activity
and my schedule changes so right now i
wear multiple hats which makes things a
little bit more difficult but back when
um yeah but in the perfect scenario in a
perfect scenario if you listen to music
and then now it's lift time uh yeah yeah
it's probably like a three hour process
where i eat two hours before an hour
before i'll shower half an hour before
i'll pack my bag and then i'll roll
it's similar with work i like to work at
home just because it's what i'm used to
for the last decade besides this year
wake up make my coffee chill on my
coffee read my emails don't answer my
emails go and shower get ready come back
bang out all my admin kind of boring x
and o's spec sheet stuff um put that
away probably eat probably do the
training deal then kind of get into
whatever may be more creative type work
whether that be content creation or or
designing clothes or something like that
that's really cool um and i just feel
like when you control the controllables
and the variables then the work insides
are much easier to do
and they're more prone to doing them 100
no i think you even mentioned the other
day about how you hate a messy house and
it's where you work and how you guys
like to get ready that's something that
that doesn't call to me like i don't
need to dress like i'm going out or
dress real when i'm working i can
literally roll up out of my boxers and
be just as productive but you got to
learn that about yourself you got to be
self-aware everyone's different yeah
what gets you and maybe coffee makes you
too wired if you have adhd or uh
whatever whatever but um
trial and error a little bit more
introspection can i put my work hat on
if i have eye boogers
literal literally yes you got a shower
like oh i don't have to shower but i
have to wash my face and brush my teeth
and i notice that i approach it
differently because i'm like in like
entrepreneur mode or whatever yeah yeah
yeah same with me like i i've noticed
now that i've made the the the effort to
like get ready i just want to do more
[ __ ] like i just feel like i'm in a
different head space i want to create
more i want to put more of myself out
there publicly too um i just feel like
even when i meet with my team i'm always
like i like i'll sit up straighter
because i just i just feel swagged out
or i just feel creative or i got to
exercise that creative part of my brain
that i don't i don't really get to
um these days just because i'm so
focused on growing business yeah a lot
of people that are uh unproductive
they're not setting themselves up right
you gotta alley-oop yourself so like
make it as easy as possible yeah so like
you know i think all guys that have been
in college know this like let's say
you're trying to like
do some hanky-panky with the lady right
you're wait what before the hecky pinky
were you were you born in the 40s
dude before the ladies he wants to hear
that you say that
what do they say they say whoopi in the
60s
no they talk about bases bro all right
that's a home rule
if you're trying to do a whoopee it's a
home run
you know before the girl comes over
you probably brush your teeth right
gotta shave the balls and yeah and you
probably please you probably uh dick
looks bigger you probably turn that's
the only reason you probably turn the ac
up a little bit right so it feels like a
more snuggly right you got it you got uh
you got her favorite movie on you got a
lot of candles or something yeah yeah
yeah have maybe dim the lights a little
bit put the blanket the house should
have been cleaned earlier yeah closer
off to the side so that's sheets yeah
tell the roommate to stay in the room
because hanky-pankies go down to the
living room yeah
so all that stuff living room is
romantic it's exciting
yeah he's staying in this room it's
provocative so all that stuff you gotta
kind of like like uh
like grease grease the ramp right so
that wine bottle wine bottle yeah condom
and then there's more chances of it
happening less obstacles in the way yeah
yeah your house smells like [ __ ]
each thing builds momentum to the next
right if the movie is on
it's cold you're already snuggling yeah
you got that oh baby you already got the
uh the blanket over the chocolate cover
strawberry you guys are connected yeah
right i didn't know you married hitch
i'm
is more likely to go down right sure so
i think yeah i'm giving it up a lot of
people that are that are
a lot of people that are uh
you're flustering them yeah a lot of
people that are unproductive i don't
think they've turned their ac up in
their production life they didn't even
think about it yeah yeah it's so they're
just like [ __ ] i can't get to work or
get productive and it's like
because i'm like what you're doing is
the chick comes in and it's just trying
to [ __ ] like gorilla pounder yeah and
like she's like whoa what the [ __ ] is
going on right now it's drive yeah yeah
so you gotta like in the night what i've
also noticed people that are hyper
productive in the day they've actually
figured out a way
where the
post-coital cuddling
is the actual foreplay for the next
event
okay you lost me
you were talking about work productivity
and then you're talking about cuddling
yes like it is [ __ ] type of things
you see those guys so you know there's
four play right yes and let's say
there's i hope you know this let's say
there's post play i didn't know the
gorilla pounding or whatever you
mentioned before but i'm not i don't
know
but let's say there's postpartum oh post
play like cuddling yeah yeah there's
post play right people that are able to
string multiple productive orgasms
together
they're able to oh yeah they're able to
make
the foreplay of something else the po or
the post play of something else the sex
guru no the the foreplay
of the other thing sure sure sure yeah
yeah right you string along successes so
for example like for me the what i've
figured out has worked for me really
good is if i get my pre-workout in
that gives me enough energy for not just
the workout but for the next thing that
i have to do oh yeah and then that and
then that
length of concentration
sets me up to not eat at all yeah so
that when i have my first meal i'm more
prone to eating something healthy so it
builds
like good sex dude work out good sex to
uh
work good sex to win win win win another
along those lines is i like to get uh
the [ __ ] i like to do least out the way
first same so i like to kind of podcast
midday or afternoon because i like
podcasting but like uh emails and calls
i hate phone calls i hate business me i
hate all that [ __ ] i'm not a good
businessman uh get all that [ __ ] at like
eight nine in the morning i schedule all
that and then and then all the [ __ ] i
hate i literally try to schedule before
noon i even eat like that dude yeah i
did kind of yeah yeah the broccoli first
then i got my burgers yeah i do the same
yeah and some people might be different
right because if if the
sometimes you don't like to get into it
like creatives i feel like sometimes
work is hardest but it's what you're
best at and you need a weird time for
that you know like if you like you're
right yeah you know so like if you're a
painter but you can't just you can't
just put that you can't schedule when
you paint no you know so that's a little
different you can right but it might not
be your best or funnest so like that's a
little different but um
i still still had workouts right but i
still uh
set the mood up for the painting for
sure so like yeah i'm gonna paint i
agree i still you get the ac brush the
teeth
maybe some music
whatever gets you going shave the balls
do all that yeah get it ready and then
hopefully i have a good painting yeah
and and to top all that off i think uh
being more self-aware that's like my
number one goal for the entire planet i
don't think people spend enough time
with themselves or their mind being more
introspective and then to piggyback on
the gorilla pounding or whatever bart's
doing uh i think my favorite
[Laughter]
i think
you have to also be um
in tune with your partner in your
instance right because all those setups
are like typical movie setups yeah like
you what if your partner doesn't like
that she loves it hot yeah or whatever
so you gotta you gotta you gotta put
some thought into all these things yeah
but i couldn't agree more
i just love the new uh
blended of the apes just when they're
like half speak english half donuts it's
just so good
it's not like that new just like the
new-ish ones like james franco is it the
last
james franco i don't know it's like 10
years now but it's like the newest of
them
i haven't seen it but the guy starts to
like speak english she's like
no
it's a [ __ ] monkey it's just really
good it's gonna head there man [ __ ]
yeah you see they're trying to make
dinosaurs [ __ ] oh yeah well
those memes are funny like there's a
real article saying like we found dna
from dinosaurs that we can now clone
every tweets like i think there's a
couple movies about why that's a bad
idea dude literally all movies there's
movies about robots being a bad idea but
here oh we're [ __ ] no we're [ __ ]
we're [ __ ] yeah matrix i just need one
good robot on my team
i mean but how long are they gonna be
good for no they're gonna be good and
we're gonna fight them all off all right
let's get wall-e ready set go ball hit
the battle bot idea i know but [ __ ] i
mean that's the only i need like an
optimus
you could go take your wall-e and fight
me an optimist who's going to win no i'm
just going to [ __ ] i don't know what
i'm going to do if that [ __ ] happens
yeah i'm [ __ ]
i don't know i'm [ __ ]
uh last question and a cool question i
don't ask anybody these but i have to
ask you because you and i we [ __ ] around
so much so we're gonna get close again
all right oh man
um here we go
what
was your first impression of geo and
bart
well that's good um that's a good
question
so i think the first video i ever
watched was bart
doing a cowboy voice over workout in a
24-hour gym
uh and so i started doing some marketing
for a company and social media marketing
like wasn't a term or a thing but i just
simply thought like i'm working for a
lifting company if i get people that
live to wear stuff more eyes get on it
like i never went to college for
business like oh i didn't major in
anything i dropped out but i was like
studying psych and philosophy like way
you're not dumb you're a pretty smart
dude yeah it was just logic to me right
like
these guys wear knee sleeves maybe like
arnis lee's and so i saw that video
you might have been in it but i don't
know like that doesn't sound like yeah
uh it was before barbara brigade so then
i reached out to bart and then i think
within the year and maybe we emailed for
like a second but not like friendship
stuff sent you some gear or something
and then i saw you guys open a gym
um and i watched some of those videos or
whatever i was probably like 23 at the
time and then
and those were like a little less goofy
you're still doing some weird voices but
you're like trying to kind of talk about
powerlifting and they're mostly just
voice over lifting um i was like that's
cool like and i knew nothing about jk i
knew nothing about any you guys i just
uh found you through powerlifting he's
like this guy's just like a deadlift
just like a weird deadlifting kid yeah i
was like all right that's cool like he's
squad bench dead not that many people do
uh and it's like oh he built the gym for
that like that's really rare too uh he
has these weird accents yeah i don't
know why he's a cowboy i don't he looks
asian
adopted he was like the funniest worst
cowboy too like the most typical yeah
and then uh and then i think i probably
didn't meet you guys until you moved
barbara brigades and we did a seminar
there before you opened i think you
opened like september we did a seminar
in august yeah yeah yeah and even that
like i kind of shook your guy's hand
said what's up but i don't think we hung
out uh your crew started talking to me a
bunch so i started talking to the crew a
lot i think they gave me mcdonald's
which slid i'm eating chicken nuggets
before this [ __ ] thing in your back
office and so i got to know them a
little bit better and then uh i don't
really remember the first impression
oppression i do remember i came down
with omar after that and hung out for
like a week pretty soon and we all
started hanging out a little bit
um
the first memory those like first
memories i guess i guess first
impression is just like how welcoming
you are and maybe that's just because
i'm [ __ ] rad uh because like the very
trip after that you guys had me stay at
your house uh and by that time i think i
figured out like you guys were if you
guys didn't know these guys are kind of
famous and like i'm just like a kid from
[ __ ] sacramento i was like damn these
guys have a lot going on for them and
they're just gonna let me sleep at their
house like what if i'm a murderer um
luckily lucky for you guys you're not
yeah you are uh and then that's what i
just felt like i was like damn these
guys like trust me were real friends
like they got like a lot of friends in
life like why would they just let me at
their house and then that's when i knew
like it was like a real friendship
i don't really remember a person like a
real impression though yeah i get to be
honest yeah i get it yeah like because i
am judgmental but like oh only
judgmental thing because i am a hater we
the whole
other episode we recorded uh was about
me being a hater really because i think
i
find all my flaws and try to fix them i
find flaws in people real quick uh and
like nothing stood out like damn bart
really annoys me with this or he's so
dumb when he does that so nothing stands
out is actually a good thing does that
make sense yeah yeah i gotta remember
like damn i hate when g did this she
[ __ ] sucked yeah yeah because
otherwise then i would keep you on like
that circle like oh they're cool enough
they power lift but like damn it really
annoys me when they
and none of that happened yeah you were
really cool um i don't remember a
specific point where i was like um like
that thing right there was the moment
yeah um i just knew that like you just
so i was fairly new to the lifting space
like i was his girlfriend and he would
got into weightlifting i was always the
cardio bunny girlfriend right um yes i
played sports but we didn't really give
a [ __ ] about powerlifting i mean
powerlifting was like non-existent in
the world and even the networking wasn't
even right like
i feel like i met everyone and no one
knew anyone yeah like i met omar's like
you know barty's like nah i've seen his
videos i was like bro you know omar like
no i've seen his videos you know like no
one knew anybody yeah like during that
era was probably 2013 or 14 like then we
all became like homies yeah but then
when i met people and i started meeting
and no [ __ ] to anyone because i i mean
i'll throw it out there dude no i have
no sh i have there's not people in the
fitness space that i'm like [ __ ] this
person this person's a dick or whatever
like it's really rare but people were so
about lifting which i'm not that when i
would meet them i was just like oh [ __ ]
we're not even in the same space like i
i don't know what to say i have nothing
to contribute here or even even like
if that's the case like
people's mentalities are just different
like you can feel vibrations like it's
not good or bad i mean and if you think
about it right like back what like 10
years ago powerlifting is such a weird
sport yeah no it's crazy and crazy it
was more extreme then and even fitness
back then it was weird too for sure now
you get like walks of life everywhere
and that's why powerlifting is cool
because anyone can do it yeah but back
then not everyone did do it freaks did
it yeah tatted [ __ ] angry [ __ ]
chains yeah pit balls yeah
those peop those are the only ones that
powerlifted i think that's probably why
i reached out to part two i was like oh
he looks kind of normal like me yeah and
that's why we liked you because it was
like it's such a weird space like you
have to be a very unique person to
pursue something so new
um like even the fit expo when we first
started like we scoped it out before we
started the gym just to kind of see
where fitness was at that time because
we were so green to it too
that when we went to the fedex we were
like what the [ __ ] kind of collection of
people is this is [ __ ] weird it's a
freak show it's a circus now it's
different a little bit yeah but still at
the top
like a lot of it's like circusy still i
mean
uh it's grown so much
uh but you were at least the marketing i
think before it was like house of pain
yeah yeah yeah just [ __ ] chains and
all that crazy [ __ ]
and then like you like depends on the
part of the world you can't lift until
someone slaps you on the back right but
now there's it's like like and then
there's like nike fitness right yeah i
think it's like it's getting closer like
this crossfit played a big role in that
yeah it did it really did but even then
it was still kind of odd yeah um so when
we met you or i can't speak for bart
when i met you i was like whoa this
guy's actually like you felt
you felt balanced you felt like you
enjoyed the good things in life and not
the good things but just like the
regular [ __ ] in life like music food
that's where i think a lot of us friends
like music and like games like we [ __ ]
around a lot whereas everyone else i
think they were i mean it's just it
calls to such a special that's cool you
like pantera i like pantera it was yeah
it was just a really odd space so when i
met people i'm like you're tight because
your goal like you you have your goals
and your d you look like you look
amazing so obviously you're disciplined
like you stick to some [ __ ] that you set
out to do
um but i just we don't we're not going
to connect yeah vibration's a little
different yeah i've always felt like
that in the industry i've always felt a
little bit different yeah i'm special
something like that yeah
but um yeah those are all the questions
i got for you man
some nosy ass people just kidding they
were great questions i like them yeah
they're really good questions oh great
answers really oh that's
that too um anything else you want to
throw in here never uh anything you want
to throw in here never all right well
yeah i'm to we're going to put all
mike's information in the description
below but thank you so much plenty of
fish yeah yeah but if you're in the
norcal area and you're looking for a
sick gym to train at go to third street
barbell from sacramento downtown
sacramento i heard you can lift naked i
heard you can lift no rules yeah there's
no rules throw chalk all over the place
showers would just sit on me that is yes
barbara doesn't have shoes
three showers each dude yes we have at
least 12 people showering at the same
time three percent booth there you go so
12 get your 12 best buds together and
shower in his shower locker room
towel there you go man drop the soap as
much as you want yeah a little bit of
who's in my mouth
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] that's a weird norcal yeah yeah
we don't do that yeah don't bring that
or vegas yeah yeah stop that you guys
can't just claim both cities now yeah
yeah we can we never done bro we got we
we did it dude we're like tupac we could
do ballet and gangster rap okay there
you go dude's from brooklyn he's west
coast rap hey there that's who we are
bro
um on that note thank you mike for
giving us your time this is [ __ ] rad
i love talking with you i love you bro
love you too
no eye contact one of these days i'll
get the i love you eye contact um and
thank you guys for listening thank you
to our sponsors and we'll catch you next
time bye